Le soleil se lève
sur le sud de l'Andalousie.
Juste à côté de l'autoroute,
d'étranges roulottes
transitent depuis plusieurs jours.
Parmi eux, des dizaines
de voyageurs gitans.
Ils ne se connaissent pas,
mais ils avancent tous
dans la même direction.
Chaque année, ils parcourent
des centaines de kilomètres,
pour assister à une cérémonie
religieuse hors norme.
Comme ces hommes qui marchent
pour s'infliger une peine,
et expier leurs péchés.
- Ça fait 3 jours que je marche.
On a un peu d'eau fraîche,
un peu de nourriture, mais pas plus.
À pied ou à cheval, tous avancent
vers ce petit village d'Andalousie,
construit autour d'une église,
et d'un miracle.
Il y a 500 ans, ici même,
la Vierge Marie
serait apparue à un bûcheron.
Depuis, sa statue appelée
El Rocio est vénérée.
Ce village porte son nom : El Rocio.
On se croirait dans un western.
Aucune rue n'est goudronnée,
elles sont en sable.
Et la ville ne compte que 1500 habitants.
Nous sommes le lundi de Pentecôte
et dans quelques heures,
1 million de fidèles inonderont les rues.
Des familles gitanes installent
des campements partout dans la ville.
Voici les mijes.
Pour cette fête religieuse,
la tradition veut qu'ils soient
les plus élégants possibles.
- Il faut toujours être sous son meilleur jour.
Il faut que les gens te voient.
Nickel !
Ce pèlerinage est un sacrifice
qu'ils font chaque année.
- C'est 1 000€ pour venir ici.
C'est très cher.
On économise toute l'année.
On n'est pas riche, seulement des travailleurs.
Sur ce camp de fortune, ils sont 30
de la même famille gitanes.
- Ici, c'est notre frigo. On ne manque
jamais d'eau ni de bière, évidemment !
Ce sont leurs seules vacances de l'année.
La nuit tombe, mais tout le monde
doit rester réveillé.
Car dans quelques instants,
le spectacle va commencer.
Il est plus de minuit,
là, dans chaque rue,
des milliers d'hommes et de femmes marchent
au son des cloches et des tambours.
En 2 h, le village perdu d'Andalousie
se pare d'une marée humaine.
La Vierge va bientôt sortir de l'église.
Cette gitane porte
son effigie autour de son cou.
Cette médaille ne me quitte jamais.
C'est celle de mon grand-père.
Quelques minutes plus tard,
les femmes et les personnes âgées,
ont stoppé net leur marche.
À l'intérieur de l'église,
que des hommes qui s'empoignent.
Tous veulent effleurer la Vierge.
Chaque année, des centaines de croyants
sont écrasés par la foule.
Chacun veut sa part du miracle.
La procession va durer jusqu'à l'aube,
dans la fièvre et la ferveur
de cette terre andalouse,
située à l'extrême sud de l'Europe.
C'est dans cette région que les traditions
espagnoles sont les plus ancrées.
C'est sur cette terre que les premiers
gitans sont arrivés en Europe,
il y a 600 ans,
Chassés du Rajasthan en Inde,
ils ont traversé l'Égypte
pour arriver jusqu'en Andalousie.
Alors à l'époque,
on les surnomme los egyptanos.
Ce mot deviendra plus tard Gitanos,
en français gitan.
- C'est mon drapeau gitan
pour  qu'il me porte bonheur,
et à tous les gitans de l'univers.
On est là et on restera longtemps ici.
Rejetés pendant des années,
ils n'ont acquis la nationalité
espagnole qu'en 1978.
Victime de racisme, ils vivaient
alors dans des ghettos.
Certains y habitent toujours,
et font perdurer leur tradition
secrète et archaïque.
Celle qui veut l'honneur,
elle doit bien se comporter !
- La loi Gitane, exige que la jeune fille
prouve sa virginité avec un mouchoir.
Mais la plupart des gitans
ont lutté pour s'intégrer.
- L'Espagne est le seul pays dans le monde
entier où nous sommes, nous les Gitans,
les mieux considérés.
- On a évolué, on peut étudier,
on peut travailler nous aussi.
C'est très important.
Pour se fondre dans cette société
espagnole si catholique,
ils se sont convertis
et sont devenus de fervents croyants.
Chaque année, ils descendent
dans les rues pour les fêtes saintes,
qu'ils se réapproprient avec démesure.
Au fil des ans,
ils sont devenus puissants,
et règnent sur les plus grandes
célébrations de la ville.
Aujourd'hui, les gitans
sont même à la mode.
Les riches Andalouses portent leurs robes,
leurs coiffures et danse leur flamenco.
Les Gitanes font rêver.
- Je ne suis pas une gitane,
mais j'essaye de danser comme elle.
J'aime dire que je suis
une gitane blanche.
Intégrés en Andalousie plus qu'ailleurs,
les gitans sont fiers de garder
leurs racines et leurs valeurs.
La solidarité, le sens de la famille,
le goût pour les fêtes extravagantes
avec beaucoup d'argent,
et l'instinct pour les affaires
sans contrat, à la parole donnée.
- L'argent ! C'est pour ça
qu'on vient dans cette foire.
À l'occasion de la Semaine sainte,
nous avons plongé dans l'incroyable
vie des gitans andalous.
La Sierra Nevada est la plus
grande montagne d'Andalousie.
Sur les hauteurs de Grenade,
tout en haut perché,
le palais de l'Alhambra,
construit par les Arabes
et terminé par Charles Quint,
a protégé toute l'Europe des invasions.
Juste en face, une montagne sacrée
baptisée Sacromonte.
C'est ici que les premiers gitans
sont arrivés autour du XVᵉ siècle.
Ils ont creusé la roche
pour vivre dans des grottes.
Ici, ils savaient qu'ils étaient protégés.
Six siècles plus tard,
ils sont toujours là.
- Kouro est le plus ancien du village.
Il est né dans cette grotte.
Il n'en est jamais parti.
- On allumait des petits feux
dans les grottes pour cuisiner.
Il n'y avait pas de toilettes
ni de salle de bain,
pas d'eau courante.
Voici à quoi ressemblait
le quartier dans les années 60.
Ils sont 4000 gitans
à vivre sur la montagne.
Ce sont alors des parias.
Les pères de famille sont forgerons.
D'autres fabriquent des paniers
qu'ils vendent dans la rue.
Ils n'ont pas le droit
à la citoyenneté espagnole,
pas d'accès aux systèmes de soins.
Et les enfants n'ont pas
le droit à l'école.
Et ce, jusqu'en 1978.
Mais tous ont un talent inné,
qui va changer le cours de leur existence.
La danse.
C'est Kouro qui a sublimé ce flamenco.
Et c'est en partie grâce à lui que les gitans
se sont intégrés à la population locale.
Il a fait des grottes une curiosité,
pour attirer les touristes
et les personnalités.
- Ici, c'est le footballeur Zidane.
Il y a beaucoup de personnalités
qui sont venues.
Il y a Bill Clinton,
il y a eu Michelle Obama.
Le prix Nobel Kofi Annan.
Il y avait des grandes fêtes
aussi avec les rois.
Ils voulaient même se marier
avec les gitanes.
Le roi du Maroc a voulu
se marier avec l'une d'elles.
Mais les Gitans ont dit non.
Les gitanes ne se marient pas
avec les rois, mais avec les gitans.
Il a créé un mystère,
et une fascination
autour de sa communauté.
La nuit est tombée et comme chaque soir,
des centaines de touristes
font la queue devant les grottes.
Ici, on paie cher pour
voir les gitanes danser.
50€ la demi-heure de flamenco,
car ce flamenco gitan ne se voit
nulle part ailleurs en Espagne.
On l'appelle la zambra.
Un flamenco très rythmé.
Et soudain beaucoup plus lent.
Aujourd'hui, dans la communauté,
les femmes ont pris le pouvoir.
Elles sont devenues propriétaires
des grottes ancestrales du Sacromonte.
Comme celle de Rosa
et de sa sœur Christina.
- Ceux qui dansent et qui chantent,
ce sont les femmes, pas les hommes.
- Les gitans ont une mentalité machiste.
Ils l'ont, oui,
mais ce sont les femmes qui commandent.
Ce sont elles qui gèrent le foyer,
qui ramènent l'argent.
Elles en font plus que les hommes.
- Mon mari est toujours près de moi,
mais ici, celle qui commande, c'est moi.
- Si on n'est pas là,
rien ne fonctionne !
Rosa s'est construit une maison
au-dessus de sa grotte.
Pour faire perdurer son business,
elle prépare la relève, sa petite fille.
- Viens là, ma fille. Allez !
Une écolière de neuf ans.
- Ma petite fille, c'est la plus belle.
Tu vas être une magnifique artiste.
Tu chantes, tu danses,
tu sais tout faire, n'est-ce pas ?
- Oui.
La petite fille n'a pas d'autres choix
que de consacrer son temps libre,
à danser dans la grotte.
- Une gitane modèle.
Je sais chanter,
je sais bouger.
Et la flamenca, comme ça !
Tu vois ?
- Et qu'en pensent tes amis à l'école ?
- Que je suis très douée et c'est vrai
et que je suis très douée.
- Dans notre famille, la danse
vient de génération très ancienne,
et ça continue toujours avec elle.
Regarde les expressions du visage qu'elle a.
Ça, c'est elle toute seule.
Je ne lui ai jamais montré !
- J'ai fini et pour dire au revoir,
je mets la main comme ça,
puis un bisous et je m'en vais.
- Allez, venez !
Installez-vous où vous voulez.
Pour la voir danser,
ces touristes ne payeront
que quelques boissons.
Car Sandra n'est pas encore
une professionnelle.
- Tu as vu comment elle bouge ?
Le talent qu'elle a
pour son jeune âge !
Grâce à leur art, les gitans
gagnent aujourd'hui leur vie,
mais ils se souviennent sûrement
qu'ils ont longtemps été rejetés.
Alors, pour garder leur indépendance,
loin des villes et des touristes,
ils se retrouvent entre eux
et font des affaires à leur manière,
avec leurs codes
et leurs rites ancestraux.
Une fois an,
ils viennent vendre leurs trésors.
Des chevaux sauvages.
- Il va se sauver !
Viens le récupérer.
Ce sont les plus rares
et les plus chers d'Espagne.
Entre 3000 et 20 000€ l'animal.
Ici, pas de contrat.
Chez les gitans,
les affaires se font à la parole donnée
et ça va très vite.
- C'est bon. 1500.
Allez, dis oui !
- Mais non !
- Il nous prend à la gorge lui !
- 1400, accepte !
C'est bon ! Allez, cède !
- Allez, cède !
- 1300. Allez, c'est d'accord.
C'est un monde d'hommes.
L'accord se conclue toujours
par une poignée de main.
Et là encore, les familles gitanes
veulent assurer la relève.
Transmettre leur savoir-faire
à leurs enfants est essentiel.
Fandi est un jeune garçon gitan
qui vient là depuis qu'il est né.
Son père l'a initié.
Aujourd'hui, il va lui montrer s'il est
capable ou non de vendre des chevaux.
Pour se donner du courage,
il est venu avec sa très jeune fiancée.
- Je m'appelle Fandi.
- Moi, Elena.
- Moi, j'ai 13 ans.
- Moi, 10.
Le père de Fandi est un puissant
marchand de chevaux.
- C'est notre chef à tous.
Le patriarche, le patron.
- Il faut avoir l'œil.
Il ne faut pas se faire avoir
avec le prix du cheval.
C'est avec le temps que mon fils
apprendra le métier.
Mon grand-père était négociant,
mon père puis moi,
puis je passerai le relais à mon fils.
- Oui, je continue
la tradition de mon père.
Voici les chevaux que doit vendre Fandi.
Des albinos.
Chez les gitans,
on dit qu'ils portent chance.
- Ce sont les chevaux
qui vont faire notre bonheur !
Un premier acheteur se présente.
- Celui-ci me plait plus que celui-là.
- Bien sûr, lui,
c'est le meilleur que j'ai.
- On commence à 4000 ?
- Non, c'est un super cheval !
Je ne l'ai même pas proposé à mon père
pour te le réserver.
Et toi fils, t'en penses quoi ?
- Tu en veux combien papa ?
- 6 000€ mon fils !
- Vous m'écoutez sinon,
chacun rentre chez soi.
Tu as dit 4000 et lui 6000.
Alors, avec respect et joie,
on se met d'accord sur 5 500€.
- Non, c'est 4500 !
- Allez, j'ai compris, je t'en donne 5000
et c'est fait. On n'en parle plus !
- La commission !
- Oui, il est comme son père.
Tel père, tel fils !
Fandi a réussi sa vente.
En quelques minutes, il vient d'être
admis au sein du cercle très fermé,
des vendeurs de chevaux gitans.
- On a vendu 3 chevaux albinos.
Ça a été une bonne vente. Dieu merci !
Et je vais en vendre d'autres si je peux.
Et ici, c'est autour d'un verre
que s'échange l'argent.
- Tout se paye en liquide,
avec des liasses de billets.
- Allez, donne-moi l'argent
de mes 2 chevaux et je veux tout !
- L'argent ! C'est pour ça
qu'on vient dans cette foire.
- Il dit ça, mais moi,
j'en ai gagné beaucoup plus.
La plupart de ces chevaux
promènent les touristes à Séville.
La capitale de l'Andalousie est visitée
chaque année par 21 millions de personnes.
Cette région du sud est le moteur
du tourisme en Espagne.
Les gitans le savent, ils possèdent
le business des calèches.
Un petit tour de la ville
coûte environ 50€.
Ce business fait vivre
une centaine de familles.
Chaque année, dès la fin avril,
leurs calèches envahissent Séville.
Lors de l'une des fêtes les plus
somptueuses de toute l'Espagne,
la "Feria de Abril".
Elle attire 4 millions de visiteurs
avec un costume traditionnel très prisé,
la robe sévillane à froufrou,
un vêtement d'inspiration gitane.
- La robe gitane, c'est le vêtement
le plus typique de notre région.
Totalement espagnole.
Il suit la mode.
C'est une robe chère, très chère.
Elle coûte entre 300 et 600€ la robe.
Après avoir été tant dénigrés,
les gitans sont à la mode.
Il y a 150 ans, la feria,
c'était leur foire aux bestiaux.
Aujourd'hui, il ne règne plus sur la fête,
mais leur stands sont toujours là.
Les Fernandez sont une famille
de gitans sévillans.
- Venez, passez là, installez-vous.
Chaque année, ils viennent
y vendre leurs beignets.
- Elle te plaît la musique ? Super !
Ça va ?
Comment ça se passe ici ?
On va laver ça et on va refaire de la pâte.
Il faut qu'elle lève parce que
cette pâte là, elle a bien monté.
Elle est parfaite.
Regarde comme elle est.
Et regarde, vous allez voir le chocolat,
et je vais mettre du sucre
pour qu'il soit bon.
Les gens aiment bien avoir
la vie douce comme le chocolat.
Les beignets,
on les fait comme ça, regarde.
Tout est fait à la main.
On fait ça depuis plus de 50 ans.
Ces beignets s'appellent des bunuelos,
ils coûtent 12€.
- C'est excellent ! Vraiment excellent !
- On adore les beignets. Venir voir
comment les gitanes les préparent.
Elles sont belles, bien habillées.
Tout est très beau.
C'est une tradition surtout.
C'est la tradition !
Ces beignets font vivre
les 30 membres du clan.
Ils en vendent 8000 par semaine,
et la famille gagne de quoi
vivre pendant un an.
Alors, ils ne font pas la fête
mais travaillent beaucoup.
- On commence à 16 h le soir
et ça ne s'arrête pas jusqu'à 7 h du matin.
Le stand est encore ouvert,
ça ne s'arrête jamais.
C'est une semaine intense,
très importante,
mais on est heureux car on ramène
beaucoup d'argent à la maison.
C'est ta mère qui est là ?
- Oui, je vais te la présenter.
Maman, viens là !
C'est ma mère, Mama Dolorès,
c'est elle qui garde notre argent,
c'est elle qui commande depuis toujours.
C'est la meilleure. Un phénomène !
- C'est de moi que tu parles ?
- Oui, je parle de toi.
Tu es la meilleure.
Mama Dolores gère l'argent.
C'est elle aussi qui distribue le salaire
à chaque membre de sa famille.
- Tu vas me donner
des sous ma gitane ?
- Je n'ai que ça. C'est ça ou rien !
Mais tu vois bien que j'ai rien.
- Mais si ! Regarde, tu en as plein !
- Allez, prends ça !
À 79 ans, elle a toujours travaillé ici.
- J'ai commencé avec un tout petit stand.
C'était dur à l'époque.
Ce n'était pas aussi beau,
le terrain était mauvais.
Mais je me suis accrochée !
Et peu à peu, mon activité a grandi.
Et puis j'ai eu beaucoup de succès.
Et c'est moi qui ai formé
toute la famille.
Parce que le Bon Dieu, il m'a donné
ce don pour entreprendre.
Et maintenant, j'ai tout ça !
Si la petite entreprise de Mama Dolores
est devenue aussi lucrative,
c'est parce que les millions de visiteurs
y dépensent sans compter.
La haute société espagnole se retrouve
dans ces casetas pendant une semaine.
Nuit et jour, ils font la fête
à la façon gitane.
On compte près de 1000 casetas,
toujours bondées.
Chacun rêve d'avoir la sienne,
pour faire des affaires ou inviter
sa famille et ses amis.
Et pour cela, il faut payer très cher.
Car louer un stand pendant une semaine
peut coûter jusqu'à 100 000€.
La feria, c'est la fête de l'année,
où le plus d'argent à Séville circule.
Les dépenses sont énormes.
Chaque soir, tu flambe beaucoup d'argent,
on boit, on offre beaucoup de bouteille.
On mange.
- Après, pendant 2 mois, on mange des
sandwichs et on a plus de problèmes.
Mais là, on dépense tout notre argent.
Et après, si on n'a plus rien
ces prochains mois, plus d'argent,
Tu trouves ce que tu peux trouver !
Être déraisonnable,
c'est le mot d'ordre de cette feria.
Au point de faire évoluer les mentalités.
Aujourd'hui, les Espagnols rêvent même
d'avoir un peu de sang gitan.
- J'aime dire que je suis
une gitane blanche.
J'adore le flamenco et je veux danser
à la manière des gitans.
Je ne suis pas gitane, mais j'essaye
de danser comme elles.
Alors évidemment, les gitans, ils sont...
Je n'arriverai jamais à leur niveau,
mais j'adore comment ils dansent,
ils ont ça dans le sang !
Si le temps de la feria,
les gitans sont à l'honneur,
d'autres n'ont pas su se fondre
dans la société espagnole.
À dix minutes de là,
dans la banlieue sud de Séville,
des gitans vivent
dans une extrême pauvreté.
Voici les 3000.
Un ghetto d'une centaine
de familles gitanes.
Nous sommes dans le quartier
le plus pauvre d'Espagne.
Le taux de chômage y est
le plus élevé du pays.
- On est des animaux ou quoi ?
On a des droits, nous aussi !
Les immeubles sont délabrés.
Les poubelles ne sont plus ramassées.
Tous, même les plus jeunes,
sont livrés à eux-mêmes.
- Qu'est-ce que vous filmez ?
Dans ce quartier dangereux, les enfants
montent la garde avec des armes en plastique.
Depuis deux mois, la plupart des habitants
vivent sans électricité.
Un générateur a brûlé.
Aucun service de l'État ne s'aventure
pour le réparer.
Les premières victimes de cette situation,
ce sont les enfants.
- On veut l'électricité !
- Regarde les câbles ici.
- On se croirait à la féria, non ?
Une vraie féria.
Alors que tous ces câbles, ils servent
à nous brancher à l'électricité,
on n'en a plus chez nous.
Il faut qu'ils remettent l'électricité.
- On ne peut pas aller à l'école
parce qu'on ne peut plus se laver.
- On n'a pas de vêtements propres.
- On ne peut pas regarder la télé,
on n'a pas Internet.
- Il faut venir nous aider !
C'est triste que les enfants
ne puissent plus aller à l'école.
Partout dans le quartier,
des dizaines de câbles
suspendus entre les immeubles.
Un système D,
comme chez cette mère de famille.
La voisine me tend un câble jusqu'ici.
Je le branche chez moi et j'ai
de l'électricité dans la maison.
C'est mon amie qui m'aide. Elle m'a dit :
"Sonia, achète un câble.
Je vais te rendre service
pour tes enfants."
Tu le branches au mur et après tu as
de l'électricité partout dans la maison.
Il ne reste plus que la solidarité
entre voisins.
- Comment vont les enfants ?
On n'a rien pour se laver, alors je dois
aller chez ma fille ou chez un proche.
On ne veut plus vivre ainsi.
On en peut plus !
On en a marre de tout ça !
Les habitants sont excédés
et refusent aujourd'hui de payer leur loyer.
Ramone habite ici depuis plus de 40 ans.
- Ça, c'est la conséquence
de l'abandon de notre bailleur.
C'est lui qui nous loue ses appartements,
et qui devrait s'assurer
de l'entretien de nos immeubles.
Mais regarde, ça fait des années
qu'il ne passe plus ici.
Ici non plus, il n'y a plus d'électricité.
On est dans le noir.
- Même pour les ascenseurs ?
- Oui, c'est pareil. Et l'eau,
elle arrive quasiment plus.
- Oui, la pompe à eau ne marche plus.
- Oui, c'est ce que je disais.
- Alors qu'on continue
à nous réclamer les factures.
Pourtant, ils ne viennent pas réparer.
Venez, je vais vous montrer chez moi.
Regardez !
Entrez, regardez !
Ça, c'est mon frigo.
On m'a donné un peu nourriture,
et comme vous voyez,
il n'y a plus de courant.
Dans ce bâtiment, vivent 32 familles.
- Bonjour, on peut rentrer ?
- Oui, venez voir.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai pu préparé
quelques saucisses pour les enfants,
et un peu de frites
que je viens de cuisiner.
Parce que sans électricité, je ne peux
pas allumer mes plaques vitrocéramique.
J'ai besoin de courant pour cuisiner.
Maintenant, je vais faire chauffer une
casserole d'eau pour qu'il prenne un bain.
On a que la bonbonne de gaz
comme au camping.
La bonbonne va me durer deux semaines,
je l'ai acheté récemment.
Sans électricité, les tâches du quotidien
sont devenues compliquées.
- Nous, les gitans,
avons souvent été discriminés.
Dans ce quartier en tout cas,
nous subissons une grave discrimination,
depuis longtemps.
Vu les conditions
dans lesquelles nous vivons,
le manque d'électricité
aggrave notre situation.
On le voit bien aujourd'hui,
nous sommes abandonnés.
Pourtant, malgré cette grande précarité,
les traditions gitanes doivent perdurer.
Même les plus coûteuses.
À quelques rues de là, dans ce quartier
modeste mais moins délabré,
va se tenir l'un des événements les plus
importants dans la vie d'un gitan.
Son mariage.
- C'est mon fils qui se marie,
c'est mon cadet.
- Ce sont les parents qui paient
tout pour leurs enfants.
C'est beaucoup de travail,
c'est tout pour leurs enfants.
Abraham a 17 ans.
Ses parents, comme ceux de la future mariée,
sont vendeurs ambulants.
- Les sacs d'oignons dans la cuisine.
Vous les mettez tout en haut, ok ?
Cela fait un an qu'il économise
pour payer ses noces.
Elles ont coûté 30 000€.
Pour un gitan, même pauvre,
un mariage doit être spectaculaire.
C'est le respect et l'honneur
de la famille qui sont en jeu.
- C'est le tapis rouge pour les mariés
quand ils vont rentrer.
Même s'ils ont investi une grande
partie de leurs économies,
ils n'ont pas pu s'offrir de traiteur.
Alors c'est toute la famille
qui cuisine.
- Fais attention à toi.
- Lui, Lui et il en manque
encore d'autres. Ils vont cuisiner.
De grosses quantités sont à prévoir,
car chez les gitans,
il n'y a pas d'invitation.
Tout le monde peut venir à la fête.
Dans la cuisine, les femmes du clan
attendent ce moment depuis très longtemps.
- Ici, c'est ma mère et là ma belle-mère.
C'est ma première fille qui se marie.
Je suis très émue.
Parce qu'elle va nous donner,
quelque chose de très spécial
pour les gitans.
Sa virginité.
Et on est très fiers de ma fille.
Pendant le mariage, une cérémonie très
spéciale et très archaïque va se dérouler.
Son but : vérifier si la jeune fille
est bien vierge.
C'est important la cérémonie du mouchoirs,
c'est notre honneur.
L'organisation mondiale de la Santé
appelle à mettre un terme à cette épreuve.
Mais les jeunes Gitanes y tiennent.
- Vivent nos coutumes ! Elles sont
si belles, elles ne se perdront jamais !
Pure de corps et d'âme,
La fille de Conchi va se marier !
Dans 24 h, ces deux familles
vont sceller une union pour la vie.
Le lendemain, tout le quartier est réuni
devant l'immeuble de la mariée.
- On arrive !
Elle s'appelle Nerea. Elle n'a que 15 ans.
Elle est encore au collège.
Ce sont ses parents qui ont payé sa robe.
Cette adolescente quittera
sa famille ce soir.
Les enfants gitans ne partent de chez leurs
parents que lorsqu'ils se marient.
Aujourd'hui c'est le jour de ton honneur,
c'est le mariage !
Son père, Ismaël, est très fier.
- C'est ma petite fille,
c'est le soleil de ma maison.
Tout le monde doit être heureux.
Il faut boire, il faut en profiter.
C'est seulement un jour dans la vie.
Elle ne se mariera jamais après,
c'est pour toute la vie.
Près de 500 invités doivent assister au
mariage, mais beaucoup ne sont pas encore là.
- Appelez la pour qu'elle vienne.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?
Il faut qu'elle arrive maintenant.
On ne peut pas attendre.
Cette mariée, cette mariée !
Cette mariée si belle !
Nerea doit danser avec chaque
membre de sa famille.
Comme un dernier dieu.
Dans l'immeuble d'en face vit Abraham,
son futur mari.
Lui aussi est entouré par ses proches.
- Chaque personne de ma famille
doit m'habiller.
Quelqu'un me met mes chaussures,
quelqu'un d'autre ma chemise.
Cette tradition gitane est réputée
porter bonheur aux mariés.
- Tu es beau !
- Tu brilles comme un sou neuf !
Une dernière danse.
Un dernier baiser d'une mère
pour son fils.
Bien marier ses enfants, c'est aussi se
faire respecter aux yeux de la communauté.
Pour l'occasion, les familles
ont vu les choses en grand.
Nerea reçoit ses derniers cadeaux.
En bas, tout le quartier
attend les mariés.
- La mariée !
- Magnifique ma belle-fille !
Les deux adolescents se connaissent
depuis qu'ils sont nés.
Abraham a demandé Nerea en mariage,
il y a un an,
elle avait alors quatorze ans.
- Nerea ! Écoute, tranquille, tu souris.
- Ma robe n'arrête pas de descendre.
- Ce n'est rien. Ne t'inquiète pas,
on va arranger ça.
- Profite de ton père, ma fille.
Tu es l'unique !
- N'oublie pas que c'est le jour de ta vie.
Il n'y en aura pas d'autre.
Ce mariage est un mariage de luxe
pour ces familles modestes.
Alors, il faut que tous le voient.
- Tout va bien. On est heureux.
- Je suis très nerveuse !
Le mariage va se dérouler
dans une salle des fêtes.
Tout va commencer
par une cérémonie religieuse.
Nerea et Abraham
sont chrétiens évangéliques,
comme plus d'un quart
des gitans espagnols.
- À partir d'aujourd'hui,
Messieurs, Dames,
ils vont fonder une famille,
leur propre foyer.
Ce sont des pasteurs gitans
qui les bénissent.
- Bénissez-les, Seigneur !
Et faites qu'il y ait beaucoup d'enfants !
- S'il vous plaît,
bénissez-les, mon Dieu !
Nerea et Abraham sont maintenant considérés
comme un couple aux yeux de la communauté.
- C'est une princesse,
c'est la plus belle !
La robe blanche de la mariée,
c'est le symbole de la pureté.
Et c'est très beau.
- La couronne, elle pèse lourd.
- Ils sont nerveux, les vêtements
sont inconfortables, la couronne,
mais il faut supporter.
Depuis petite, on l'habitue aux vêtements,
au poids de la couronne.
La fête commence à peine.
Mais trop d'invités sont venus.
- On est débordés ! Il n'y a pas
assez de place pour tout le monde.
On est déjà 500, 600 personnes,
mais d'autres gens vont arriver,
c'est ça qui me préoccupe.
Les familles gitanes sont nombreuses.
Les cousins arrivent de toute l'Espagne.
Toutes les femmes portent
leur plus belle robe,
leurs plus belles parures.
- Ma Gitane, qu'est-ce qu'elle est belle !
Et c'est pour ça que je l'aime tant !
Tous dansent avec les mariés
au son d'un orchestre gitan.
Tous attendent le gâteau.
Il est presque 2 h du matin
lorsqu'il arrive enfin.
Pour en avoir une part,
il faut donner un billet.
C'est une jarretière à la gitane.
- 2 640€ pour les mariés !
- Dans une autre salle,
on va préparer avec les femmes,
la cérémonie du mouchoir.
Car pour que le mariage
soit totalement scellé,
il manque encore un rituel,
la cérémonie du mouchoir.
Une tradition séculaire, secrète.
- On pourrait mettre la table au centre
pour que les anciennes se mettent ici.
Nerea va devoir s'allonger sur cette
table et prouver sa virginité.
- La mariée sera ici avec un mouchoir.
Elle va prouver qu'elle est vierge.
Ensuite, le mouchoir
sera montré à la foule.
C'est une juntaora qui le fait dans
la tradition de génération en génération.
Sa mère, par exemple,
attestait ma virginité.
Dès que les petites filles naissent,
on les éduque ainsi,
elles doivent donner leur honneur.
Elles font attention, elles ne
peuvent pas avoir de petits copains,
avant leur mariage.
La juntaora est cette femme
en veste noire.
C'est une gitane réputée pour sa sagesse.
Dans quelques instants,
à la manière d'une gynécologue,
elle va vérifier si l'hymen
de Nerea est intact.
Ce rite gitan date d'un autre temps.
Celle qui veut l'honneur,
elle doit bien se comporter !
Si Nerea n'est pas vierge,
elle fera la honte de sa famille,
et ne pourra pas se marier.
Dans le machisme de la communauté gitane,
l'honneur des familles repose
sur la douleur des femmes.
La jeune fille redoute cette
cérémonie incontournable,
mais elle ne la fait pas contre son gré.
Elle veut prouver ce que
les Gitans appellent la pureté.
La juntaora la rassure
et lui prodigue ses derniers conseils.
Les hommes, eux,
n'ont rien à prouver du tout.
Ils attendent dehors.
Et la cérémonie, c'est maintenant.
- Devant la mariée, je ne veux que les gitanes
âgées et la famille des mariés. D'accord ?
- Et les autres,
vous êtes en cercle derrière elle.
- Allez, les femmes âgées, ici !
Les caméras dehors !
La vérification de l'hymen
ne dure que quelques minutes.
Nerea est maintenant
officiellement mariée.
En signe de respect,
son père et son grand-père
la hissent sur leur dos.
Pour leur porter chance, les invités
jettent des kilos de dragées.
Ce mouchoir appartient, maintenant,
à la belle-mère de Nerea.
Elle le brandit tel un trophée.
Il est près de 5 h du matin.
Nerea peut enfin souffler.
Abraham, lui, est félicité par les hommes
pour la virginité de sa femme.
- Cette cérémonie des mouchoirs était sublime.
Elle a fait vraiment honneur à sa famille.
C'était magnifique, très beau !
Tout était parfait.
Elle s'est très bien comportée.
- Je suis heureuse et très fière.
- Et qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire maintenant ?
- On va vivre ensemble dans notre maison.
- On sera toujours ensemble.
C'est comme ça chez nous.
Chez les gitans espagnols plus qu'ailleurs,
les règles sont strictes.
Le divorce est interdit.
Dès la fin de la cérémonie,
le couple s'installera dans un appartement,
dans le quartier de leur enfance.
Pour Nerea et Abraham !
Les jeunes gitans s'éloignent
rarement de leurs parents.
Il y a six siècles,
à leur arrivée dans le pays,
les gitans ne priaient aucun dieu.
Mais pour mieux s'intégrer, ils ont
embrassé les croyances des Espagnols,
pour devenir de fervents catholiques.
Ils ont mis près de 400 ans
à obtenir le Saint Graal.
Avoir l'honneur de participer aux processions
de la plus grande fête religieuse de l'année,
celle de la Semaine Sainte.
Ils ont même fondé leur propre confrérie.
Aujourd'hui, on vient du monde
entier pour les voir.
Dans un quartier populaire
au nord de Séville,
Antonio, 35 ans,
se prépare à un grand jour.
Ouvrier dans une usine de carton,
il n'est pas encore marié.
Toute sa vie est dédiée à la religion.
Sur son lit, un costume.
Il appartient à la mystérieuse confrérie
catholique des Gitans.
- La dévotion, c'est ça
le plus important pour moi.
Toutes les Fraternités, toutes
les confréries ont leurs propres idoles.
Et moi, j'ai toujours fait partie
de celle des gitans,
et je serai toujours parmi eux.
Antonio était enfant quand il est entré
dans cette fraternité.
- Je devais avoir 5, 6 ans.
Lui, c'est mon grand-père qui
m'a initié à suivre ce chemin spécial,
devenir un frère chez les gitans,
Et là, c'est lui.
La tradition, c'est la tradition
depuis notre naissance.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose
que j'ai choisi à l'âge adulte,
mais je suis ainsi depuis
que je suis tout petit.
Lui, est ce qu'on appelle durant
la Semaine sainte un Nazaréen.
C'est-à-dire un pénitent.
Ce costume est celui que portaient
les condamnés à mort,
pendant l'Inquisition espagnole.
- Là, je prépare la cagoule
qui recouvre la tête,
le visage et les épaules,
et je mets ce cône à l'intérieur.
Je ne mets ma cagoule
qu'une fois dans la rue.
De la maison à l'église,
je n'ai pas le droit de montrer mon visage.
Quand je suis à vue des passants,
je dois le cacher la.
Les Nazaréens doivent être anonymes.
Même si je prends le bus,
je dois la porter.
- Bien droit, comme ça.
-C'est une expérience
qu'on partage en famille.
Là, ma tante m'aide à m'habiller.
- Oui, cet écusson, c'est moi qui l'ai cousu.
Et les boutons aussi.
- On vit tous là, en famille.
Et ça nous unis un peu plus.
Les prochaines heures s'annoncent
éprouvantes pour Antonio.
Désormais pénitent.
Il doit se cacher,
n'a plus le droit de parler,
manger ou boire pendant près de 15 h.
Le temps que va durer la procession.
La nuit tombe sur Séville.
C'est l'heure pour Antonio
de rejoindre l'église des gitans.
Comme lui, les pénitents arrivent
les uns après les autres.
Ils sont près d'un millier.
Là, ils sont entre eux
et peuvent retirer leur cagoule.
Seuls les plus pratiquants sont élus
pour participer à ce rituel.
Il y a des femmes, des hommes
et même des enfants,
tous habités par la foi.
La cérémonie va commencer,
Antonio doit remettre sa cagoule qu'il devra
garder jusqu'à la fin de la procession.
Le public n'est pas autorisé à assister à
ces moments d'intime piété au cœur de l'Église.
Voici les "costaleros".
Ce sont des porteurs.
Des hommes qu'on ne voit jamais.
Ce sont aussi les fidèles
les plus costauds.
Dans quelques instants, ils vont soulever
sur leur nuque ces immenses trônes,
de près d'une tonne chacun.
- Le trône est construit
sur une planche avec des tasseaux,
qu'on place ici
pour la porter sur la nuque.
Puis, on met ce linge très serré
sur notre tête.
On renforce cette partie
car elle nous sert aussi à porter.
Il faut bien serrer.
- On a des douleurs tellement intenses
au cou qu'il y a un moment,
où on ne sent plus rien dans notre corps.
Ils sont 32 à se glisser
sous chaque trône.
Ils vont fournir un effort hors du commun.
40 kilos rien que sur leur nuque.
- Vous êtes courageux !
Jusqu'à la mort ! Pour lui !
Ces hommes vont rester pendant
16 heures sous le poids du Christ,
et de la Vierge des Gitans.
Cette nuit, c'est toute l'Andalousie
qui vibre de cérémonie sainte.
Au même moment, à Grenade...
Dans le village troglodyte,
berceau des gitans, la même ferveur.
Mais ici, on chante l'âme des gitans.
Des chants puissants aux balcons
que l'on appelle les Saetas.
- Vive la Vierge des gitans !
Et vive le Sacromonte !
Là, ils crient la fierté de leur origine,
et l'héroïsme des porteurs épuisés,
qui marchaient depuis l'aube.
La procession est terminée et ce soir,
les gitans ouvrent leurs caves
aux riches Andalous.
Ils les invitent à célébrer la Vierge,
leur offrent à boire et à manger.
- C'est la première fois
que je viens ici.
Et pourtant j'habite à Grenade.
Je ne connaissais pas.
Danser aux côtés des Gitanes,
un privilège pour ces femmes espagnoles.
Pour les gitans, ces fêtes sont une façon
de s'intégrer encore un peu plus.
Le lendemain matin, à Séville,
la procession gitane se poursuit.
Les infatigables Costaleros portent
la Vierge à bout de nuques,
depuis plus de 16 h.
Les plus jeunes pénitents sont épuisés.
- Je suis nazaréenne.
C'était un peu long.
Moi, j'ai marché pendant 7 h.
Je participe depuis que je suis
toute petite à la Semaine sainte.
La Vierge des Gitans
a fait le tour de la ville.
Elle retourne à son église.
Depuis près de 50 ans,
c'est aussi grâce à elle
que la communauté gitane rayonne.
Les Costaleros peuvent enfin
se reposer et s'hydrater.
Chaque année, ils sont
plus nombreux parmi les gitans,
à vouloir s'infliger cette épreuve.
C'était finalement assez court,
mais vraiment bien.
Après 16 h, on a quelques douleurs,
mais ça va.
Quand tu fais quelque chose que t'aimes,
tu n'as pas mal.
Je suis très heureux et en même temps
triste que ce soit fini,
jusqu'à l'année prochaine.
Cette Semaine Sainte a rassemblé plus
de 2 millions de fidèles à Séville.
Avec leurs rites secrets
et leur art de l'émotion.
Les incroyables Gitans poursuivent
sans relâche leur fusion andalouse.